hello everyone this video kicks off our
series of screencasts on supervised
sentiment analysis i just want to
provide you with an overview of the
problem and of the kind of work we'll be
doing and also a rationale for why we'll
be doing it
so here's an overview of the entire unit
i want to in this screencast motivate
for you the idea that sentiment analysis
is a deep problem and an important
problem for nlu not only scientifically
but also for industrial applications
uh in the next screencast i'll give you
some practical general tips for doing
sentiment analysis
following that we'll have two short
screencasts that introduce our core data
sets the stanford sentiment tree bank
and a new data set called dynacent
after that i'll introduce the code base
that we'll be working with on the
assignment and the bake off that's
sst.pi which is included in the course
code distribution and i'm going to use
that code to illustrate some important
methodological issues surrounding
supervised analysis in general which
would be hyperparameter tuning and
comparison of different classifiers to
see whether they are different in some
significant statistical sense then we'll
talk about feature representation both
for large sparse linear models with hand
built features and also with more deep
learning oriented distributional
representations and that will be a nice
segue into the final unit which is on
using
recurrent neural networks as classifiers
for supervised sentiment analysis my
hope is that this unit can provide a
refresher on core concepts in supervised
learning
introduce you to the problem of
sentiment analysis which i think is as i
said a central problem for natural
language understanding and also sets you
on your on your way toward
doing the assignment and the bake off
and possibly building projects in this
space
for the associated materials as i said
we've got a bunch of code sst.pi is the
core module and then we have a notebook
introducing the stanford sentiment
treebank as a dataset
we have a second notebook that's on what
i've called hand-built features and
mostly linear models
and then a third notebook that's on
using neural networks which more or less
pushes you to using distributional
representations instead of hand-built
features
although as you'll see the notebooks
explore various combinations of these
ideas
the homework in the bake off is in the
notebook homework sentiment
and i'm going to introduce that problem
in a separate screencast
the core readings are the two papers
that are oriented around our data sets
the stanford sentiment treebank and
dynacent and as supplementary readings
you might enjoy this compendium from
pang and lee it's a kind of overview of
the whole field of sentiment analysis
and it poses challenges and questions
that are still relevant to this day and
then goldberg 2015 is an excellent
overview of using neural networks in nlp
very generally um but with lots of
helpful notation and so forth that we're
aligned with and that might help you get
a feel for the landscape of modeling
choices that you might make in this
space and in subsequent units for this
course
so i want to start by just motivating
the idea that sentiment analysis is an
interesting problem because you often
hear people say things like sentiment
analysis is solved or it's overly
simplistic or just too easy and i think
none of those things are true and to
motivate that i just want to do a little
data-driven exercise with you so for
these examples you should ask yourself
which of these sentences expresses
sentiment at all
and for the ones that you think do
express sentiment what is that sentiment
is it positive or negative or maybe
neutral or something else
so you might think those are
straightforward questions but this is
going to get difficult really fast
consider the first example there was an
earthquake in california this is
probably going to sound like bad news to
you
and many sentiment analysis systems will
assign this negative sentiment but we
should ask ourselves is this actually a
sentiment latent sentence it is on the
face of it merely stating a fact and we
might hold that for sentiment to be
expressed we need some kind of
subjective evaluative perspective to be
included in here like it was bad that
there was an earthquake in california
and absent the it was bad clause this
might just be a neutral statement of
something that had happened
but the important point here is that
unless we settle these questions we'll
have continued indeterminacy about what
we're actually doing
the team failed to complete the
challenge
is that positive or negative we might
agree that it's more than just a
statement of fact although it's a
borderline case even for that question
but if we did decide it was sentiment
laden we would need to figure out the
perspective of the speaker is the
speaker advocating for this team we're
advocating for a different team
right
we win we lose it's really going to
depend uh on how the speaker is involved
and that of course is going to have to
become part of our definition of what
we're doing when we assign sentiment
labels they said it would be great on
the face of it this expresses no speaker
perspective at all this is merely
reporting what somebody else said and we
need to decide for those obviously
different perspectives what we're going
to do in terms of sentiment analysis
because after all this could continue
they said it would be great and they
were right which is straightforwardly
positive but it could also continue they
said it would be great and they were
wrong and i think that reveals that
sentence three is not so obviously
encoding a particular speaker
perspective whereas these clauses are
what really tell the story for us as
sentiment analysts
and then we get into things that you
might call non-literal use of language
the party fat cats are sipping their
expensive imported wines this has a lot
of positive language in it maybe only
fat cats is the thing that sounds like a
direct sneer
but i think we could agree that overall
this is probably negative in its valence
and that will be a challenge for our
systems and also a challenge for us in
just characterizing precisely what was
done here in terms of sentiment
here's a similar example oh you're
terrible this might be a criticism and
it might therefore be straightforwardly
negative on the other hand it could be a
kind of teasing form of social bonding
that overall has a positive effect on
the discourse how are we going to
resolve that kind of context dependence
here's another one here's julia bastard
it's got some negative language even
something that's kind of like a swear
but this could be a friendly jocular
phrase of some kind um and we'll have to
sort out whether it's friendly and fun
because of its negativity
or whether this is straightforwardly
just a positive sentence
and then here's a case that's just going
to be a challenge for our systems this
is of the movie 2001 this is from an
actual review many consider the
masterpiece bewildering boring slow
moving or annoying there is a not a lot
of negative language there in fact
there's very little that's positive
except masterpiece but i think we can
all anticipate that overall this is
probably going to be a positive review
of that movie
so that just shows you that even if
we're clear about what we're doing in
terms of sentiment the linguistic
challenge here is
significant and we could also extend
that to sentiment like long-suffering
fans bittersweet memories hilariously
embarrassing moments these are things
that are going to blend positivity and
negativity and all sorts of other
emotional dimensions in ways that just
make sentiment analysis very difficult
to do reliably
and that's a nice segue into this topic
of sentiment analysis in industry
because of course
sentiment analysis is one of the first
tasks that was really transformed by
data-driven approaches and it was the
first task to really make an impact in
industry uh there are lots of startups
and companies that offer sentiment
analysis tools and it has obvious import
for things like marketing and customer
experience and so forth
and i would say the first thing i would
say is that to this day the sentiment
from industry so to speak is that
sentiment analysis tools still fall
short this is from an article from 2013
and the
gist of it is anyone who says they're
getting better than 70 today is lying
generally speaking for whatever notion
of 70 we have here i think we can agree
that that's too low and that we as a
field ought to be offering tools that
are better
this is another kind of equivocal
headline the motion ai technology has
has great promise when used responsibly
affective computing knows how you feel
sorta the sorta is kind of like the
equivalent of 70 percent here and i
think it shows that there's a lot of
work to be done if we're going to have
the kind of impact we want to have in
the technological sphere
and there's another dimension to this
which we're not going to really get to
capture but is worth planting in your
minds because this could become projects
right we're going to do classification
of sentiment into positive negative and
neutral
and that's often the starting point for
these industry tools many business
leaders think they want these pie charts
that point out like 30 negative 70
positive and then in q2 the negativity
is slightly up
and that's truly a leading indicator of
something it looks like negativity is on
the rise but the issue is what do you do
how does this help with decision making
merely classifying these texts and
showing change over time is not enough
for any business leader to take action
what we need to know are
why this is happening what the
underlying factors are basically what
are the customers saying beyond these
gross classifications into positive
negative and neutral
and we should be pushing ourselves to
design tools that can offer that next
layer of insight
affective computing this is a kind of
transition into the wider world here
we're going to focus on just sentiment
analysis but you could think about
emotional analysis and all other kinds
of kind of context dependent expression
in language put that under the heading
of affective computing this is a diagram
from a paper i did a few years ago with
more at south uh it's a diagram of
emotions and other kinds of moods that
people feel
the arcs give you a transition so they
show that people tend to transition
systematically from one emotional state
to another
so what we're seeing here is basically
just that this is a very high
dimensional space it's not just positive
negative neutral we have a wide range of
feelings and moods and emotions and
states that we go into and there's a lot
of structure to how we experience those
moods in our lives and it would be great
to break out of the simple
positive negative mode and tackle all of
these dimensions
and in that spirit here what i've done
on this slide is just list out a whole
bunch of other tasks that you might
consider adjacent to sentiment analysis
but they are meaningfully different from
sentiment analysis things like
subjectivity bias stance taking
hate speech microaggressions
condescension sarcasm deception and
betrayal online trolls polarization
politeness and linguistic alignment
these are all deeply social things that
are influenced by and shape our language
and i've selected these papers in
particular because all of them have
really nice either crisp statements of
the problem and or really great public
data sets that you could use for
experiments in this wide world i think
that's a very exciting space to explore
as a kind of next step from what we're
doing in this unit
but back down to earth here our primary
data sets as i said are going to be the
ternary formulation of the stanford
sentiment tree bank which is just
positive negative neutral
and also the dynacent data set which had
which has that same ternary formulation
the sst is movie reviews dynacent is
mostly reviews of products and services
i think heavily biased toward
restaurants because the underlying data
is from
yelp and then for the bake off we're
gonna have a new dev test split uh we'll
use sst3 as well as this new one of a
corpus of sentences from restaurant
reviews you can see that dynasty might
be an asset here
they all have this ternary formulation
and i'm hoping that the combination of
these data sets gives us a really
interesting perspective not only on
sentiment analysis but also on kind of
how we design systems that effectively
transfer across domains and maybe learn
simultaneously in multiple domains